hello welcome back to a venture time V
logs and yeah it's a shame that I copied
over the last one there the part where
you like you juggle the fire and stuff
like that now nobody's gonna see that so
I was I'm really sorry about that just
not no I just think you don't want me to
be in these you know just those two
because you were clearly upstaging me
you know and the other one I copied over
you know where you ate the cap I mean I
thought that was pretty impressive but
dared me to actually I did
I know it's ironic is it was a cat I
showed triple cap dared you but
nonetheless that's why I wanted to keep
it out because that was in bears and
didn't say triple cans to a triple dog
and you know maybe the fat don't want
you arrested for killing an animal but
because I do for you regardless we have
her parents now is the name of this
episode well yeah the stuff you know
just like what Finn does for Jake I
don't go through all this stuff for you
yeah it's like I didn't get that segue
until you know I saw this one I was like
oh cuz you did half of the stuff in this
episode in that last video that's a
Romeo get your bottles yeah I'd do that
for you yeah weird so anywho we got this
episode where Lady Rainicorn is that how
is the lady pregnant okay her parents
are gonna visit Jake and there's this
big dog Rainicorn battle and he's afraid
that he's not gonna they're not gonna
like him so he pretends to be a
Rainicorn and Finn is his goblin Butler
and he just keeps abusing him because it
amuses the parents and then they try to
eat them and all this other stuff
and finally Jacobson says no stop and it
turns out it's okay because a dog saved
the father in like the big war and then
at the end they all eat soy a human with
probably the best edit so the edits to
these cartoons you know our prey flame
they're always really quick but I love
if they build a well first of all
another great clue with I thought humans
were extinct that's a narration to the
whole apocalypse thing uh but second I
love
they're saying so human it's like wow
Finn you taste great and it's just
building up how uncomfortable it is and
if i see finn go down there and he's
gonna try it I know it's gonna cut soon
but you think it's gotta be a clown his
eyes are gonna get big but instead he
smiles and then it cuz it's like just it
was it was just so brilliant it's just
so insane it's still SOI so they can get
away with it but still it's and even
pull those smiling things adds up
I really like this episode and I guess I
felt more in this one the Navy are the
ones like theirs and me you can help me
out with this like there's other clues
maybe like they said the parents said
they came from like them
was it the crystal ferger's whatever
wearable dimension the crystal dimension
I'm like well why would they say that
unless it was gonna tie into something
later it doesn't come back at any point
maybe maybe okay y'all that people by
people on the forum saying don't give
away too much don't you know the point
where you said though way too much cuz
they say dawn the next episode but like
ya know I see that's one of the things I
like I like but you can talk about this
stuff without necessarily giving it away
yeah it's like you know oh yeah this
might lead to something but it's not you
know like this happens so well actually
my my question is this they're from the
crystal dimension which is where all the
crystal people were three trunks but you
never saw the to mix we were in tree
trunks thrown burn well it's possible
I'm just saying you mean like the
dimension can't possibly be was just
like I could only see that the Apple you
see her going through yeah that's the
last minute so Mayo's her going to the
crystal yeah
kind of like when they were leaving it's
like this whole warp thing yeah that's
good of him that saying that was
probably her throne well but we're gonna
miss it I thought was really good
episode I really like the you kind of
know where it's gonna go you know that
okay it's important to be yourself that
sort of thing it's gonna come around and
the only thing I love the physical
violence in this I love how love it is
quiet like you don't hear Finn screaming
through a lava it's just for him like
you can hurl him and just landing on the
ground they're really hard slacks and
like when he hits the where was the
record player it falls it's like there's
just no sound from and that just makes
it more painful yeah which I find
usually you won't hear like some sort of
scream that's like nothing so I like
that it's silent um and yeah even though
it was kind of predictable it's still I
thought was still really funny and yeah
I had a really good ending
the only other thing I'm curious to are
though our rainicorns are the females
always longer is that how I think yeah
yeah so yeah that's all I get Susumu I
love rainicorns I think they're awesome
you just like Nyssa Karine um yes of
course they do get caught like one
Korean word I was like oh she's the dad
one other thing too I know I said before
about just say it again her Korean voice
I don't know what she's saying but it
just sounds adorable that it's just such
a beautiful language yeah maybe it's
just a language I just here I'm just
like yeah it's just so soothing and nice
it's just it's really cool I like the
language personally I laugh I watch a
lot of K dramas and it's relaxing for me
there are times or output on Korean
music because it's just relax I don't
know what the hell they're saying but
it's relaxing I like just hearing Lady
Rainicorn to do an album oh my god
that'd be awesome
oh she should you know you'd like it
yeah are you are you done with Korean
dramas over there every Facebook pose
you have is superb Korean drama thing I
don't get like it's just stuff that only
you like people watch Korean dramas
which is like what three more of you in
the United
on Kate soap opera people represent yeah
I will be fascinated see how many I got
the glasses I got people actually watch
Korean yeah oh well okay yeah we got
that oh no there's gotta be more I'm
sure there is forget a little sidetrack
Jason would you think of this a sec oh
I'm sorry I was distracted by your
babbling oh I'm sorry I'm distracted by
your dumb I can accept that
cuz you're dumb wait a minute I'm okay
with that too dumb ki brain no we were
talking about episode you just tried to
toss in a way to talk about the episode
okay no I I liked the episode my
favorite part of the episode was
actually the beginning part with the
eggs beemo you want more eggs yes
this puts more on the plate mean just
never touches them when they're all
relaxing be most just like yeah I like I
like putting them hello BMO BMO's great
also voiced by the Lady Rainicorn oh
really
same voice actress yeah okay um no um
considering Jordi is Filipino
and I had to meet her family going from
one culture to another is really
difficult and you want to try your
hardest to impress them and you know
make them know that you know you want to
be accepted but at the same time you do
kind of lose it bidding yourself because
you just want to impress and impress and
impress and this is a great example of
that in my opinion yeah I think it's
something where a lot of people can I
mean I think we've seen this setup
before and I gather
oh yeah movies and stuff like that but
it's still I think the reason you do see
it so much is it's still something
people can relate to you know you want
to please the mother and father you
don't want to piss them off um so you're
kind of willing cuz you know if this is
someone you're gonna be with for a very
long time or rest your life whatever
it's like you've got to be with the
family to it so it's like the more you
can get along you know the better
so yeah I mean I like to have thought
was fun I like the when I was I know in
the opening when they had the sun
shining it I liked the little dust
particles it yeah those little things do
you know they do make a difference
ah but know what this episode also does
though with that was it wasn't just Jake
not being himself
it had an outside impact if Jake just
wasn't being himself in there that's
fine and dandy but by him not being
himself in trying so hard to impress it
was actually affecting people around him
but yes relaxing it's kind of like it
went that extra mile with the whole yeah
it affects yourself and you know it'll
really wear you wear on you but in this
and actually went even a step further
and started affecting you know the other
people he cared about because he was
just so impressed with it like poor Finn
carrying him around good yeah some of
that stuff I was Sara like you know
cookie just like get little wings in the
back I said why did fit have to carry
and I get the last thing I'll say before
sign-off here I like how in the
beginning when Jake is serum-free if he
insults Finn or what the finn is like
you know oh but that is like you know
come on homie help me out and finn just
gets this really heavy smile like it's
just suddenly it's going cuz i just
really want to help out my dad and
that's just i again there's just
something so strangely positive about
them that's just really addictive but
also funny
which I really like there's just because
maybe it is just so out of character for
people to do it's like come on help me
out like most people be like okay just
saw how comedy goes but with this it's
like he gets even more happy I think
that unexpectedness is not only really
funny but it's really it's really a
beat'em really positive so I like that
again I really like the friendship
between them and this so uh
closing thoughts I liked one of my
favorite parts actually was right at the
beginning Finn's first idea how to help
Jake we're gonna paint ourselves like
rainicorns and you see them and it
starts out with the ketchup in the
mustard and I'm going oh Jesus no and
then but then the animation turns and
you see like everything turns into
rainbows and at school I'm like oh I
love it it's great wait wait how they
see is hilarious and then and then it it
just drops everything it drops the
curtain and it reminds me when I was
little because I suck at drawing I
cannot draw stick figures and like as a
kid it was the most frustrating thing
for me cuz I imagine like this entire
thing I wanted to draw and I dry it out
and then I was done drawing and I go
what the crap is this and that's exactly
what happened there they're like it's
like Jake opened his eyes and he's like
oh my god what did we do we have to
clean the house we can't do this look at
us it was it was really neat it was
really neat to show how the kids you
know with their imagination and how it
looks awesome and sometimes ideas sound
way cooler than they actually are they
represent your total lack of artistic
ability and yes Jason in what way did it
bring to life your total lack of
artistic ability one point in time I was
trying to draw the Village People and
the problem was is yeah again I'm not
really a good artist but I've tried to
draw the Village People and they turned
out to be like pigs that's beautiful man
it kind of hurts now that you bring it
up it's kind of funny actually that
makes you maybe maybe he'll kick you out
this time instead of you guys kicking me
out I think it's a good idea I think you
should Jason I will not juggle fire
again you can go draw a pink over
there maybe it'll turn out to be college
babes the village mm-hmm I guess finally
he's gone